[Musik]
jetzt Hilfe Schnecken
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir jetzt mal Hefeschnecken auf die
Zutaten stehen ja schon bereit ich zeige
euch mal was ich für den Hefeteig
verwende denn das wird ein rosaner
Hefeteig ohne Lebensmittelfarbe sondern
mit natürlicher Lebensmittelfarbe ich
verwende für den Hefeteig einen Würfel
Hefe 250 ml rote Beete-Saft 80 g Zucker
etwas Vanilleextrakt 600 g Mehl einen
Teelöffel Salz ein Ei und 90g weiche
Butter die Rote Beete sorgt jetzt hier
natürlich für den pinkfarbenen Touch und
auch für den Geschmack weil sie das
nicht wollt könnt ihr natürlich ganz
gerne Milch verwenden oder Wasser und
dann einfach mit Lebensmittelfarbe
arbeiten wie bei anderen Hefeteigen auch
ich merke so richtig ich bin so voll im
Barbie wurde
wie bei anderen Hefeteig auch nehmt
jetzt die Hefe verrührt sie mit dem rote
Beete Saft und Zucker in einer
Rührschüssel und dann kommen die übrigen
Zutaten dazu und am besten Salz und
Butter einfach zuletzt und den Teig dann
10 Minuten lang schön geschmeidig
verkneten
der Hefeteig ist jetzt wunderbar
verknetet den nehmt jetzt hier heraus
formt ihn zu einer Kugel und lasst ihn
dann eine Stunde abgedeckt aufgehen oder
auch gerne eine halbe Stunde bei
gerstufe im Backofen so bis er sich
verdoppelt hat der sieht schon
wahnsinnig gut aus
für die Füllung nehme ich 200 g Früchte
ich habe jetzt hier Himbeeren und
Erdbeeren 50 g Zucker etwas Tonka passte
250 g Quark 40 g Stärke und ein Ei könnt
ihr hier die Früchte einfach mit Zucker
und Tonka verrühren in einem Topf und
das ganze so ein bisschen zerstampfen
mit dem wacker und dann einfach
einkochen lassen
[Musik]
die Hälfte der Stärke gibt dir jetzt
hier zu den kalten Früchten damit koche
ich nämlich jetzt die Früchte ein und
die andere Hälfte der Stärke die kommt
dann hier so Creme
[Musik]
während es jetzt noch ein bisschen Kopf
kann ich hier schon mal die Zutaten
verrühren nämlich Quark
mit etwas stärker die Stärke bindet das
ganze genauso wie das Ei
[Musik]
sobald die Fruchtmasse eingekocht ist
könnt ihr sie erstmal auf einen Teller
geben da kann sie nämlich kurz abkühlen
jetzt ist die Fruchtmasse abgekühlt das
kommt jetzt gleich beides auf den
Hefeteig drauf ihr könnt es aber auch
einfach jetzt schon vermischen ganz wie
ihr mögt
zeige ich euch erstmal den wunderschönen
Hefeteig
guckt euch den mal an
[Musik]
jetzt Roll ich hier erstmal den Hefeteig
auf etwas Mehl aus der ist heute muss
ich sagen ein bisschen weicher und
klebriger deswegen brauche ich etwas
mehr Mehl zum Ausrollen als sonst aber
alles gut
schönen großen Rechteck
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier die Käsemasse drauf
ich habe es jetzt vorher nicht verrührt
damit sie es für euch richtig schön
gleich marmoriert
[Musik]
und jetzt die Fruchtmasse drauf
verteilen und auch verstreichen
[Musik]
und jetzt noch schön aufrollen am besten
geht es sogar mit Hilfe dieser Matte
dann könnt ihr hier schon mal gerne eure
Ofenform etwas Austern
[Musik]
und dann mit Hilfe eines fahrtens die
Schnecken schneiden ihr könnt auch ein
Messer natürlich verwenden aber mit dem
Messer zerdrückt ihr die Schnecken und
mit dem Faden schneidet sie praktisch
von außen nach innen und dann schneide
diese zurecht je nachdem was für eine
Ofenform ihr habt und dann müsste das
perfekt passen
[Musik]
dann kommen sie schon in euren Backofen
gerne einfach in den kalten Ofen stellen
dann den Ofen einschalten und dann gehen
sie noch wunderbar auf und backen dann
auch gleichzeitig und wenn ihr habt
sogar mit Dampfstoß
[Musik]
jetzt sind die Hefeschnecken gebacken
und ich muss sagen die sind schon
ziemlich Barbie like aus richtig schön
pink da kommt jetzt noch eine Klausur
drauf einfach etwas Puderzucker nehmen
Zitronensaft und zum Färben auch gerne
wieder etwas rote Beete Saft oder wenn
ihr rote Beete Saft nicht mögt einfach
bisschen pinkfarbene Lebensmittel
verpasste ich würde schon sagen so jetzt
oder
passt
direkt auf die lauwarmen Hefeschnecken
Mama
[Musik]
könnt ihr noch ein paar
gefriergetrocknete Erdbeeren und
Himbeeren drüber bröseln
dann sind die fruchtschnecken fertig ich
weiß noch nicht was ich von der Optik
halten soll muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
aber Barbie ich finde es toll ja
definitiv
dann sind die fruchtigen Hefeschnecken
jetzt fertig und ich würde sagen jetzt
fehlt eigentlich nur noch kennen zum
probieren wobei nee selbst ist die Frau
ich probiere jetzt selber
[Musik]
oh
nein
okay ich will mal nicht so sein ich
wollte doch gerne dazu
[Musik]
riecht
oh mein Gott
[Musik]
lecker oh mein Gott
ich kann gar nicht mehr sagen als
probiert das Rezept gerne aus die besten
die allerbesten
[Musik]
habe oh mein Gott
wirklich unbedingt die sind so gut
die kann man nicht mehr trocken
also das Rezept findet ihr auf
sallys-blog.de und in meiner App
macht's gut bis zum nächsten Mal und
falls ihr euch eine Motivtorte wünscht
zum Thema Barbie dann schreibt gerne in
die Kommentare dann mache ich gerne auch
noch ein Motivtorte oh ja eine
Motivtorte muss sein ich habe mir
gedacht farblich
aber eine Motivtorte wäre eigentlich nur
noch also wenn ihr möchtet gerne
schreibt eure Wünsche auf dann mache ich
das direkt nächste Woche bis bald
tschüss
[Musik]
[Applaus]